[Musica]
nella vita
a me è capitato di di viaggiare in giro
per il mondo e da tanti anni vivo il
medio oriente e vivendo il medio oriente
io non sono andato a cercarmi la guerra
e la guerra che che ha scelto un pochino
me e sono qui a cercare di di
raccontarvela e per raccontarvela la
guerra sta negli occhi di di shamil a
una una bimba che io ho conosciuto in
ospedale sotto le bombe e questa bimba
quel giorno mi ha dato tanta speranza
perché in quella notte era la prima
bambina che arrivava e aveva le braccia
e le gambe perché cinque membri arrivati
prima 4 non ce l'hanno fatta e uno era
rovinato ecco e per me è stato un
momento di grande speranza perché
finalmente una bimba che se superava
l'operazione non è comunque semplice in
una zona di guerra superare un
operazione aveva una brutta ferita
all'addome però al termine di tutto
questo perché le guerre finiscono tutte
sarebbe tornare a giocare a a correre
bene la bambina è stata operata e dopo
un paio di giorni ce l'aveva fatta
stava bene però non parlava era muta e
questo ha spinto la speranza di quel
giorno mi ha fatto capire che chiunque
vive una guerra porta dentro una ferita
al di là delle braccia e delle gambe che
non ci sono più e che fare allora no io
ci provo e quel pagliaccio che dice come
si può risolvere questa cosa non me lo
chiedono ogni tanto poi io sono
sono un clown io io penso che nel
momento in cui noi torniamo a dare ad
ogni bimbo la possibilità di sognare
andiamo ad ogni bimbo la possibilità di
pensare che lui potrà fare una cosa
bella
nella vita o della sua vita
io ho conosciuto tante persone in guerra
e quando hanno una cosa bella da fare la
guerra non la fanno
quando uno ha una cosa bella da fare
nella vita non decide di fare la guerra
ma gare la combatte quasi sempre la
subisce ma non la decide non difficile
fare la guerra
ed è questo ecco e io veramente penso
che sia veramente importante per mettere
i bambini di usare il proprio proprio
talento la propria in intelligenza
ecco qui l'intelligenza non ce n'era più
io vivevo lì sono immagini che si
ripetono oramai e in quel momento io ho
visto il fallimento del genere umano io
non dico che mi auguravo però se fosse
arrivato un asteroide si ricominciava
daccapo e devo dire che non sono
completamente impazzito perché
nonostante tutto questo c'erano dei
ragazzi di bimbi che avevano ancora la
voglia di giocare col pagliaccio e
questo veramente mi ha salvato la vita
e davanti a un sorriso di un bimbo
c'è sempre una speranza questo l'ho
toccato veramente con mano è davvero
pensare che in guerra si perde tutto e
quelle ancora oggi la loro casa dopo
qualche anno davvero c'è sempre sempre
sempre
sempre una speranza davanti a
soddisazione di un bimbo e adesso
guardate basta veramente lasciarli in
pace i bimbi perché lo stesso posto
l'anno dopo per un mese ci hanno
lasciato senza bombe
abbiamo iniziato la scuola il primo
giorno di scuola
incredibile la scuola il mi chiedo
sempre come si fa senza la scuola
importante un anno 2 3 4 5 6 7 anni non
vai a scuola come fai a fare
l'astrofisico se non vai a scuola
la ballerina se non vai a scuola
ecco vuol dire davvero negare i sogni e
bimbi e nel momento in cui tu né chi
sono i bimbi poi crescendo vivono una
rabbia così grande che può essere che
trasformino il loro amore che hanno in
odio
ecco c'è una cosa però adesso poi
toglietevi dalla testa che chiunque
cresca in un luogo d'odio che la guerra
lo è o di questa una scemata incredibile
perché ho tanti amici che sono cresciuti
con me li che hanno vissuto come le
guerre e che ora fanno i clown pur
avendo tutte le ragioni razionali per
poter per odiare ecco poi mi si chiede
anche ogni tanto e non ricordando che io
sono un pagliaccio perché si fa la
guerra no perché è chiaro che tra la
pace che abbiamo visto e la guerra tutti
sceglieremo la pace no ebbene la una
guerra non sono qui a a cercare di
indottrinare nessuno ecco però io nel
mio racconto visto che la guerra bene o
male si fa per due motivi principalmente
uno sono i verdoni i soldi
l'altro è il potere o meglio il
prepotere chi decide e guerre
queste due cose qua le ha ammesso il
primo posto davvero e se è difficile
definire il il potere per potere del
caspita i soldi
me lo sono chiesto ho fatto fare una
piccola indagine non il pagliaccio ma
persone
e incredibile il business della guerra
90 91 milioni di dollari quello che
fattura la guerra l'industria della
guerra in un anno come si fa a fermare
un business così dura 91 milioni di
dollari faccio fatica anche a dirlo
pensarlo poi però io lavoro tanto con i
bimbi no ai bimbi mi avrebbero subito
chiesto ma quanto costa
quanto costa questo business 14 trilioni
di dollari cioè di un dollaro che esce
che fattura del business della guerra
tutti noi ne paghiamo quasi mille non
esprimo giudizi in merito
lascio lascio a voi ecco questo è il
cuoricino del clown naso rosso è una
cosa bella da fare nella vita
chi decide le guerre non ha niente di
bello da fare e decidere guerra non ha
cuore non ha logica umana
io questo lo guardo io perché ogni tanto
nella vita capita di dare troppo
importanza e soldi e successo diciamo
anche se sono fanno parte della vita
ecco lo metto qui all'ultimo posto lei
non è una statistica non è un numero
shamil a non parlare
perché nun tirata fuori dalla sua casa
solo lei sotto l'esplosione non ha visto
che la mamma papà fratelli e ci hanno
provato è i medici gli infermieri gli
psicologi che è chiaro sono quelli che
guariscono i bimbi poi l'ultima ruota
del carro hanno sbattuto dentro il
pagliaccio e con un piccolo gioco aveva
cominciato a sorridere a parlare potete
immaginare la gioia grande no l'ho
provato il fatto che io ho scelto di
fare il pagliaccio
per me questa è la mia cosa bella da
fare nella vita e si è in quel momento
realizzata ed è vero è l'augurio che
faccio a tutti di trovare una cosa bella
da fare nella vita e di provare la gioia
purissima che io ho provato in
quell'istante in quel momento
come fate a capire se una gioia pura è
molto semplice perché io in quel momento
non avevo in mente dei soldi del
successo del per potere perché in quel
momento il cuore il mio cuore
l'asino rosso è andato al al primo posto
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]